one of the most useful questions to ask
when you're building a low fidelity
prototype is whether a user can easily
make the app do the thing it's supposed
to do this may sound like a very basic
question and it is but it's actually the
most vital thing to ask at this point
for instance one of the things the user
might want to do in our example app is
check off a task they've completed we
need to think about how a user will
achieve this task from the starting
point of I have opened this app for
first-time user we may need to have an
instruction screen but in general there
are three common patterns for dealing
with user flow the first is to have an
app that does only one thing and so only
have that one screen a good example of
this is your common calculator app the
second is to have a main screen that
functions as a menu of options for
various things that you just can do in
the app and then have each task occur on
its own screen finally you can have the
first screen of the app be a place where
the users can complete the most common
tasks the app will be used for and have
a secondary screen for the menu so in
our case we can't use the first pattern
since our app has multiple functions
that leaves us with a choice between a
user flow which starts on a menu screen
and having a user flow which starts on a
screen on which the user can check off
tasks as time has gone on the second
pattern has become much more common it
is generally better to be able to
isolate the most common use cases and
have those achievable from the main
screen like this for the same reason
mobile notifications are best when the
user can perform some action directly
from the notification without opening
the app itself